Alex Jones the Infowars conspiracy
theorist you know that he's going to
weigh in on the allegedly looming arrest
of the failed former president Donald
Trump here is Alex Jones with some kind
of emergency alert of some kind here's
his I challenge you to understand his
explanation of what's going on this
indictment of trump will make him the
number one candidate he's our candidate
this will add 10 15 points to him in in
the Republican primary polls okay so
first of all I actually don't think
Jones is wrong with that I do think
initially if Trump is arrested and it
doesn't directly interfere with his
campaign it will help him I don't know
about 10 to 15 points I was thinking
more like six to eight but I I agree
with this part at least in principle
well absolutely shut out to sanus
yourself if this is assured like Elon
Musk said to win Trump the presidency in
2024 in a landslide why on Earth will
the system be doing it
because they're scared it's the same
reason the U.N just indicted Vladimir
Putin for evacuating children from a war
zone something that happens in every
major war
including in England during World War II
including in Russia during World War II
as well
So within a matter of days in fact it
was Friday that both
Trump are you following this God I hope
someone is following this and can
explain it got the news he'd be indicted
and that Vladimir Putin was indicted so
whether you love Trump or hate Trump
whether you like Putin or hate Putin you
have to understand this is part of the
same globalist system that is moving
against leaders they believe are not in
line with their operations right
globalished exactly
um why do these sort of unique events I
mean listen the the in the arrest of a
former president if it happens it's
never happened before it's literally an
unprecedented event in the United States
why do these events trigger these wild
conspiracy theories which by the way
they always seem to somehow be very
Putin friendly but that's another part
of it
um when you have something happen that
is unprecedented or rare or difficult to
comprehend in some sense
it triggers people's assumptions about
the world and it makes them sometimes
question them
and when you have something the
indictment of a president counts but
something like a horrible school
shooting which also triggered horrible
conspiracy theories from Alex Jones when
the events are complicated or difficult
to understand or horrible or whatever
people end up uncertain and they end up
confused and in such situations people
might look for comfort in an alternative
explanation or narrative
that is coherent and makes them feel
like things are less uncertain around
them and so one of the things that
conspiracy theories often do is they
simplify Complex events oh Sandy Hook
right we've got uh the interplay between
um the gun culture and ready access to
guns and then some people say mental
health and then someone goes what about
video games and then someone says what
about woke and right although woke was
not a subject then all the stuff
people don't want to believe wow a
random horrible event caused by all of
these different factors it's easier in
met for some people
to say it was a planned and staged event
that's what this was and that's why
where you get to that now here it's all
it's kind of the opposite sometimes
conspiracy theories take something
simple that people just don't want to
believe and they dress it up to make it
more complicated well there might just
be evidence Trump committed a crime and
so he would be arrested nope don't like
that conclusion so instead it's the
international criminal court is
coordinating the Trump arrest with
charging Putin because of some
evacuations and globalists and then also
DeSantis and the polling and all this
different stuff so sometimes a
conspiracy theorist's motive is to
simplify a truly complex event sometimes
a conspiracy theorist motive is to make
a simple event whose explanation you
don't like much more complicated so
people go wow I don't know what the hell
is it behind this well maybe what's
behind it is there's evidence Trump
committed a crime
and what would be appropriate in a
country with accountability would be an
arrest am I convinced the arrest is
coming tomorrow I'm not but in the
context where we believe it is that
would be the explanation behind what
Alex Jones is doing here